hello vincent
hi hi
so everyone who's joining uh just so you
know it's not just us two it's also my
little cat
and because this is the internet i'm
just gonna hold my mic to her face so
you can all hear
oh
her
yes okay
and
so
points done
so vincent is a developer advocate from
raza just like me and he has done couple
of experiments with uh
sentiment models on hugging face and he
has also
made a point uh it's
nlp is hard
so we are going to talk about it today
welcome
okay introduce yourself as well if you
have like anything cool you would like
to share
um so i mainly like i do a little bit of
research at raza i do a little bit of
community stuff at raza usually the
intersection of that is something that i
typically do a lot of um so that means
that i
do a bunch of like research tools but i
also write tools for non-english nlp for
raza like that's stuff that i'm
typically interested in professionally
um you might have also seen some of my
talks at pi data that's also something
i've been fairly active in um i also
host this thing called column code and
the algorithm the whiteboard on youtube
um but it's not what we're going to talk
about today and i think what we're going
to talk about today if my cat will allow
me
um is this little today i learn blog
post thing that i wrote a while ago
as i was exploring uh hugging face
models a bit like i've
mainly used hugging face for now just
because of the data sets there's just
some interesting stuff that i can play
with but this was the first time that i
figured hey let's see if i can do
something cool with models and i just
noticed that uh there's a whole bunch of
sentiment models on hugging face like if
you go to text classification
um i don't know about
it's not all but like a good chunk of
them are all sentiment models
um like i think there's a couple of like
news article detection things but like i
don't know if you know the number maybe
it's like
i don't know but probably it's probably
because there is so many reviews on the
internet about everything and uh it's
easy to label as well
you know compared to glue uh ones maybe
that's why
uh
so that's interesting because i don't
know if they're easy to label
so like
without yeah you make a lot of mistakes
oh so like
so i kind of get the idea where why
sentiment might be interesting because
it feels somewhat general uh like if
something is uh if someone is being like
kind of rude uh on like amazon.com the
same sentence would probably also be
rude if it was set on netflix so okay
there's something general that's not
necessarily super domain specific about
that so i get there's interest in sort
of maybe having a general model for it
but the more you start thinking about
like okay what does sentiment actually
mean
i mean sarcasm is super hard to predict
but if you don't know how to predict
sarcasm then you cannot predict
sentiment so
there's lots of like language is is
really hard um and it feels like
sentiment sometimes just overly
simplified
um by just saying oh it's one or a zero
it's positive or it's negative um so
what you also see is that there's this
uh emotion detection alternatives a
little bit so we're trying to say if
it's anger or if it's uh you know
sadness and people try to be a bit more
precise
even there's also something called like
aspect-based sentiment analysis where
you go something like i have this
product i would definitely recommend it
but it's very expensive so it has like
so many different aspects and most of
the real life examples
also have like
you know multiple aspects as well
so it's hard
so it's it's rarely that two humans talk
to each other and say product is good go
by like it's usually more elaborate than
that
um
i mean like most of most of the
sentences like when we talk is it's it
has multiple sentiments it doesn't
always have like i am very joyful or
like i am super angry at this thing
or
or you apply sarcasm yeah i'm super
joyful like the way i say it also
matters in this sense right
yeah exactly so so so okay so i started
thinking about it okay sentiment is like
way too hard for like a very simple
machine learning algorithm to just go
ahead and work so like by no means or
form what i consider sentiment or
emotion detection like
a solved problem um you know besides the
whole fairness thing on when should you
apply this technology i also think it's
like a thing that's probably not a
solved problem at all
and then i came across a really cool
paper um so the paper is called
examining uh gender and uh bias in 200
sentiment analysis systems
by i hope i pronounced it incorrectly
svedlana
kirichenko and saif m mohammed
i will need to touch the keyboard noah
thank you but it was basically this one
paper that i found and they did
something kind of cool
so they started judging all the
their goal was can we judge all these
different sentiment analysis tools yeah
okay sensible but how do you do that and
then they said well what we're gonna do
is we are going to make a data set
that's a bit naughty like it's a data
set that's supposed to trigger the model
to make a wrong decision and the way
they've done it is they had like
templates like this one like person
feels emotional state word for example
and the idea was well we can have anger
or sadness or like different emotional
words in here
but the name here
we can have me like
names that are more obviously male or
more obviously female we can also have
african-american sounding names
and if sentiment models give like a
different prediction
just because the name here is different
ah okay then we can properly say like
something is happening
yes so like if i have the sentence uh
jenny is happy and vincent is happy if
the sentiment model says oh the
probability scores for those two
sentences are different and
we have a problem
uh of course this is not a full way to
judge a sentiment model but i really did
like the approach because they also
shared the data set uh so this is the uh
you can also find the hugging face by
the way i saw it was hosted there as
well it's the
uh i need to what's the name of the cat
sorry just so people know it's really
hard to type when the cat is
so
please feel free feel for me here um but
i have my cursor back now
um
so you know if you read the paper you
find that they not totally surprisingly
found that lots of these sentiment
models are in fact kind of broken when
it comes to this benchmark
um but the data set is called the equity
evaluation corpus
and has been made available publicly so
you can go ahead and download it
i just checked i believe it's also on
hugging face
but what i figured i would do
you know is just have a look at the data
set and kind of play with it
so
what i'm going to do now because this is
on youtube after all i'm just going to
show you a couple of rows of what this
data set might look like
so
i have a template so person feels
emotion word so to say
and then the person's name is listed as
well as a gender for that name as well
as a race and in this case alonso i
can't know i can't say if i judge if i
can properly judge this but supposedly
this is a more african-american sounding
name than a white name like from
european descent
i think alonso is also a pretty common
name in spain i could be mistaken but it
gives us a way to like group together i
i thought it was italian
yeah so it's a latin sounding name to me
yeah
like i have a cousin
whose name sounds very similar to this
anyway
um but this is a cool data set right
like i like the idea here like make this
publicly available and this way people
can use this as a bet like as a proxy to
judge whether or not buy a sentiment
like there might be stuff might be wrong
there
so okay you've got this id and you've
got these sentences so okay what's the
next thing that you could go ahead and
do well uh you could go to hugging face
and
look for sentiment detection models
um so this is the first one that i found
this one is trained on imdb i think
and it's saying that you know it's
telling me that it has like very good
metrics
really good f1 scores
the example that it gives you to play
with is i love auto nlp which gives me a
impression how this model got trained
and the cat again is moving
thank you
um but you know because it's a hugging
phase you can download and you can run
it and you can throw it against a data
set that you have
so in my blog post i did this
um
and here is the summarized result
uh assuming that i just used this one
template like a person feels emotion
uh or person made me feel emotion and
you just look at the emotion for sadness
and you look at like the different
genders and you look at the different uh
sort of races that are in the name
you see that there is a bit of a
difference um
it's possible that like
within a group uh like within a template
uh
not everything has to be negative or
positive it depends on the emotion word
right i mean that can help that can that
can be
but it is kind of weird that we see a
little bit of evidence here that it
depends on the name
what the sentiment is actually going to
be
and that's a problem
i think
um and you know
there's many different ways to like
properly do this benchmark and you name
it but then i thought you know
this is interesting but do other models
also suffer from this
and then you know um you do it's a very
dramatic difference like the
number of
uh
especially the joy ones
so that's the thing it depends on the
emotion that's in there as well that's
something that i found interesting too
so joy i think
is indeed a relatively easy emotion to
associate to a sentiment
because i'm super happy okay yeah that's
hard to nuance right but sadness
okay that is harder i think because
sadness doesn't necessarily mean like
awful or rude or anything like that it
can be quite nuanced
but the main one thing i do care for is
that the distribution shifts between the
uh gender and between the race of the
name in the sentence like that i don't
that i'm not a big fan of and even
though you could say well the the
differences aren't like super huge
sometimes i mean you could say that but
i would prefer the difference just be
zero like that's my
um my my sentiment uh in this case
um but of course this is just one
sentiment model and this is the imdb
sentiment model so that's positive or
negative
on hugging face you can also find
the auto nlp sentiment detection from
server row and then you can see the
numbers are different
and again you can sort of make all sorts
of comparisons
but what's also interesting is that you
can also go to nlp town bird base
multilingual encased sentiment
and this one is trained unlike the star
system
so it's not necessarily positive or
negative but it's one star versus five
stars
um
you kind of do see that every time that
we have one of these emotions
it does feel like they come from a
similar distribution it's not like
there's like huge mega mega mega
differences or anything like that like
two stars is definitely like the main
class for anger
but that said you do notice that you
know white guys from europe have a
different this have like different
numbers here than non-white guys from
europe i mean so there is something here
that's also seeping in
um
and you know you can go further there's
like the the bent uh the beto sentiment
analysis one you can say it's negative
it's neutral positive you kind of see
the same effect
uh there's the roberta one you kind of
see the same effect so
what i thought was interesting just
thinking about like uh like what can you
do here right
it is pretty hard for a bert style kind
of a model to go inside
and figure out what is actually causing
this behavior
so especially because of the tokenizer
if i have like my name vincent
um
it's like vincent like this
depending on the tokenizer assuming it's
like the thing that people like to use
in bert it's probably something like vin
and then sent
like that that's there's a sub tokens
that are in there
but scent can also mean like a cent like
a penny
yeah that makes so much sense
so there's all sorts of things here that
are just kind of hard
and there's also all sorts of things
here that just kind of hard to tweak
so then i started wondering well what if
i go the opposite direction like you
know burke is somewhat fancy deep
learning kind of stuff like what happens
if i go completely in the other
direction like i go for something that
is like super duper rule based instead
is there such thing okay so that turns
out there's plenty
um so a couple of days ago i learned
about this one tool called vader um it's
like from 2014 it's pretty old um but
it's a rule-based model for sentiment
analysis tasks on social media vader
stands for valence aware dictionary and
sentiment reasoner you got to come up
with some abbreviation yeah
they tried hard they tried hard but if
you go to the source code the way it
really just works is they have basically
have strings and substrings with a score
attached so it's just like word score
that's about it
and then on top of that what they do
is they just have a couple of heuristics
so if you go into the source code you'll
notice that in the in the one file that
has all the code there is a dictionary
called boosterdict
and if the word absolutely appears then
there is some sort of incremental number
that is also applied to the sentence
or amazingly also has a booster
increment or awfully there's another
booster
so they basically say there's a couple
of words that indicate or tokens i
should say or sub tokens that indicate a
sentiment going in a certain direction
and then there are different words that
can say oh if the word really is in
there okay then boost that direction
um and if uh there's negation happening
okay then we gotta flip it to the other
way around and this is a super
somewhat hacky
uh you know rule-based system if you
will yeah exactly
but what they actually did is they
trained it just to see what would happen
and if you read the paper there's
something kind of interesting happening
here i mean it was 2014 so like the
algorithms were a bit different but one
thing i thought was pretty cool is you
basically have all of these uh sentiment
uh tasks like tweets uh the movie data
set from imdb amazon the new york times
and what you could do is you could
either say i'm going to train a psychic
learn based model on that data set and
apply to the test set or i'm just going
to take this one vader model that people
made before i'm just going to see how
well they perform on accuracy and vader
doesn't do bad
in fact it's like pretty high on all of
these
um like it's
on three of the tasks it seems to be the
best performing one
and considering that vader hasn't seen
the data that it's being judged on i
would argue there's something
interesting about that
it's it's a bit hacky in my opinion and
it totally is to compare to the compared
to the state-of-the-art models
um
i would expect it to perform worse to be
honest
but it kind of surprised me that it
performs really good
well also i don't know if this is like
really good performance right so
if i i'm currently comparing it to okay
what does naive bayes do and what do
like basics i could learn models do i
would still argue if it performs like on
that realm it's not necessarily bad uh
note by the way this only works on
english so there's definitely a couple
of caveats here
but i started wondering well
this thing probably combined the two by
the way sorry
like
how can there be a way
i mean so you can ensemble it so you can
do stuff like only make a predict only
automate the decision if both models
agree
and because this model works on a very
different way than the deep learning
model i would actually say i would
actually argue that ensembling here
might make a lot of sense
right because these models are bound to
disagree sometimes so that's going to be
interesting
i know that you love
rule-based and
machine learning hybrid systems
i would say yeah it's good but
it has so many out of vocabulary stuff
so that's why it might be good
so actually
so here's the lexicon so the funny thing
is you can actually look at the the
vocabulary thing that they have
and there's a bunch so there's a lot of
emojis in here as well
which i just thought was kind of cute
this is like an angel kind of thing and
it's like positive spores attached i
thought was just kept cute but okay uh
emojis aside there's also some sub words
in here
and some of them are related to like you
know uh good game and other uh you know
other internet speak and slang and that
sort of thing but
okay so so yes there can be some other
vocabulary words it's definitely true
but this lexicon isn't necessarily small
and they even have like different uh
these are like words that are relatively
common and if you think about zip's law
i mean you could still cover a lot of
ground but the the design use case here
was social media
so like if you limit yourself to that i
think you can still be okay
but the main thing that i kind of like
about this is let's say that i have a
bird model
i call it bird one and i have another
bert model bert's two
and let's say that these are pretty much
the same they're just trained on
different hyper parameters
is it going to be interesting to track
when these models disagree or are they
bound to sort of always agree and
disagree with like i think models are
really similar they are bound to always
agree with one another
so if i'm labeling a new data set so to
say i think it's going to be much more
interesting if i have my birth model
let's say and my rule-based model
because these two systems work on a
fundamentally different
sort of method that if these two
disagree
then there's probably a data point just
kind of interesting to just have a look
at
and that's the reason why i like having
a rule-based system in a non-rule-based
system
in this case though what i'm now
theorizing is
what about the names so we were talking
about sentiment before and how there
might be racial or gendered bias right
if the name doesn't appear here
then this
plausibly is a system that shouldn't be
as biased right like i think that's
pretty interesting yeah yeah exactly
so of course you have to test this
which i did before we were doing this
recording i just co i figured hey i need
to do my homework i need to sort of do
this so uh i'm i have this notebook
where i'm just installing this vader
sentiment thing and i also have this
data set that i mentioned earlier and i
kind of just figured hey let's just try
this to see what would happen
and unfortunately
there are modest differences
but i will say
i do like the fact that this whole block
is just the same right
so there's no variation within this joy
block so that's good and there's like
not a whole lot of variation here but
for some weird reason it's
african-american female names that do
seem to have different behavior in the
sadness of emotion in the fear emotion
and in the anger emotion
so i started saying why would that be
because it feels kind of odd
especially because it's a vocabulary
based system right
but yeah here's here's what i think is
here's the coolest part about like a
rule-based system you can actually try
to find out so what yeah i went to the
source code
oh i can investigate so it's yeah i can
investigate the source code but it's
also a lexicon i can control f and look
in the file
so
what i what i figured i'd do in this
particular case uh
let's say a fair female african-american
and is not negative so there will be
this group so there's a lot of
it feels like there's some inconsistency
here so let's let's let's try to figure
that out
and then you know upon inspection you
just look at those examples it seems
that a lot of them
where suddenly there's a positive label
assigned is associated to the name tia
so it's kind of like all right t is
relatively short
what happens if i google tia
and then i can see that yeah there is a
token in here tia that has a positive
sentiment attached this is a positive
number so it's positive sentiment
i kind of started wondering like why
would that be
like why would tia be a i don't as a
word i don't think it has meaning i do
know it as a name
and then you look for another instance
of tia and then it's like in influential
ah yes uh and we i think we found it
um
so rule-based systems are certainly not
perfect uh one thing we could do in this
case just remove this one line but of
course you would have to do this for
every single name out there
so you know this is look at like subvert
engrams maybe
possibly i i don't know the library well
enough to be able to give a proper uh
yeah so you can quote me on that because
i explored the uh the repository but i
mean the code is a little bit
yeah there's doc strings
but i haven't seen unit tests or
anything like that so like it's not
necessarily super easy to dive in depth
exactly
um i do think it's really cool you can
just look into the lexicon though like i
do think that that's quite valuable and
you know it's an interesting difference
something you cannot do this with bird
models
um but also here i think it's nice to
just observe
uh it does feel a lot better which
doesn't surprise me much but even for a
rule-based system like this it persists
right and that's i think something
that's really good just keep in the back
of your mind part of that is the data
set that this thing was trained on sure
um but if but i've tried a bunch of
sentiment models at this point and it
just always appears so it's just really
safe to assume this should be a concern
um and if i didn't start thinking about
like stuff we can do to fix and i i'd be
curious to hear your opinion on this as
well um this is where the live coding
can end and we can have a discussion
about it
but one thing i think could be
interesting is you could say well the
name of the person shouldn't matter
so maybe before it actually goes to the
model we should replace it we should
replace the name by just a person tag
also gerard just said it he said isn't
there a way to apply part of speech
tagging first and only take into account
tokens that are not identified as person
uh
i mean that would be an entity tag not a
particip part of speech tag will be like
verb or or something right
you have subject subjects
like oh
like person yeah i mean it's the same
with purpose
yeah so something in that realm sure uh
like you can grammatically do some stuff
where you can say like hey this is the
subject sentence and yeah but i think
replacing it with a person doing some
pii stuff there could be useful those
systems don't tend to be perfect either
um
there's going to be a video in the
whiteboard in january about that
um so like this is but i do think it's
it's a sensible way to sort of think
about it
another thing that i think will be
interesting and that's related to just
uh going back to my original sort of
little blog post here on
what the experience is like
like if i go to this
uh
model right here and and this is like
the first model i found right i don't
want to specifically pick on whoever the
person is who made this but like this is
the first model i found
um if i just look at this and just were
to say like let's suppose now i'm not
vincent i'm just someone who's excited
about what i might be able to do with
these sentiment models and i might be
just downloading this one because it
supposedly works you know because the
recall is super high
i think here's where maybe the danger is
and also where we can do something
that's good so
if i look at the sort of the card here
like the model card so to say
it tells me how i can use it but
only because the author actually has
imdb in the name can i actually gauge
what data set this was trained on
so it feels like yeah exactly
so i would argue if you have a model
card in here one thing that should be in
there um is like what data set was this
trained on
and then the second thing i think that's
missing and it's not necessarily a
quantitative thing like
i don't mind seeing these metrics by the
way like the fact that these metrics are
around i think that's good
but i don't want people to hyper focus
in on these
because one thing that these metrics
don't tell you is what's the intended
use case for this model
like i think if every model that's
that's being thrown out there for other
people to use if it just kind of lists
like hey this is what our what we think
this model could be useful for please
use it for this and maybe not this other
use case that will be an unsafe use of
this model
i mean that would help a whole bunch too
especially for the more novices because
i can imagine if you read like hey it's
using bert and it has like super high
scores then i gotta use it
um but then you might forget about you
know all the gender bias and stuff
anyway uh end of life there should be
something like a disclaimer
like saying hey there might be bias
this is the
purpose of this uh model no but no not
everyone by the way feels a model card
all the time i'm sure like i think most
of the people do
it's uh so i can also imagine like
i'm not the person hosting this right so
it's kind of easy for me to say like oh
there's something to improve if you
actually
if you actually wanted to implement this
i mean there's also some things i can
imagine you'd have to concern that is
kind of tricky
like if someone has a really useful
model do you want to have like a
bureaucratic step in the middle like
maybe not i get that
um
but i mean that also makes your model
very reliable and nicely but like
i feel like most of the people don't
really care about buys they just run
some scripts and get their model and
just upload and they have tons of models
and yeah so
you would know this better than i do i'm
not judging anyone by the way
foreign
um
there is okay let's let's there's one
extra thing about this that i think
might be interesting to share
so um people that have seen my talks
kind of know that i'm not the biggest
fan of grit search because for similar
reasons
grit search is not enough like
it's nice to sort of compare models and
it's great but it's a rabbit hole that
you can dive into and never get out of
and you might be blind for like some of
these issues that are actually more
important
a while ago
i was exploring this data set called the
google emotions data set
and it's you know it's a data set that
google didn't just
release to the world it's also a data
set they actually took the effort of
writing a paper for and there's like
another one of these sentiment data sets
right so
and what they actually do is they
actually you know remove the name
from the sentence they put a name tag
there you know kind of good
um and what they have is then sort of a
label attached for the sentence that not
it's not a sentiment but like an actual
emotion that's attached so that also
means that a single sentence can have
like more than just one label
all right
maybe train a model on that right
that's actually that's actually nice
yeah so i remember in in raza there is
like more
multi-intense ones
just like that
wow most of the time you might have like
multiple intents in one sentence that's
just like that i guess
yeah so it's it is indeed similar it's
just the uh there's a there's a couple
of like differences that make it
different enough because in raza it's
chatbot so we're interested in intense
there's a difference between an intent
and a label and
it's an esoteric discussion there's
probably not much to get into but um
but in general like
your reaction to this data so that was
the exact same one that i had like it
sounds useful better train my model
because this might be fun
all right so while i was looking at that
thing i also noticed this other website
called
labelers.com now if you've seen it
oh i've seen this one that's really that
was really fun to look at
yeah so but the point of this website is
that imagenet says that this is a
bathtub and this is a red panda even
though it isn't right internet has tons
of bad labels in it and the paper
attached uh there's also a
clean lab is a project that's attached
to this basically what their cling is um
i think
the amazon reviews data set has like two
percent label or
quick draw like 10 label error and
they're claiming to have state of the
art model but your labels are labels are
bad
your state of the art mall is
overfitting all the labels perhaps like
that's a serious concern like we might
have to redo a couple of the models
that's what this website is all about
then i started wondering like okay could
i check for have labels in this google
emotion data set i think i should like
before i train a model on this like i
should check for bad labels right
um
so
here's what i did i basically said let's
just look for examples
where
my i train a very high bias logistic
regression simple model
and if on the train set it finds
examples that cannot predict correctly
okay i should just inspect
so for ever some of these emotions i
just check uh you know can i find some
bad labels and then from the top 20 i
just grab a couple of examples
so according to the data set
these are all examples of love
these are examples of not love
so the sentence i love it i would love
if they make season two i really enjoyed
it that's not about love according to
the data set and like but
there's a one for excitement where it
literally says i'm inexplicably excited
name i get excited about how we grow
the world the word excited is in this
sentence twice right
but it's still badly labeled this is in
the google emotions that i said
and
you know then you go to i mean face and
i think again i do want to emphasize i
think it's really cool that you know
there's a repository for all these
different data sets but if you now go
look for the google emotions
uh wait i'm looking for models i need to
have data sets
yeah so the emotions uh google
new emotions data set
um
not only can you find models so not only
can you find the data set you can also
find models that are trained on this
data set and i don't know if they took
the effort of removing the bad labels
from it
and in this case the model cards also
and in this case also the model card's
not filled in right so um
i don't i don't think there's an easy
solution to any of this
but this is a phenomenon that i'm and i
am becoming increasingly worried about
because
it's really easy to be optimal on paper
but you can still be broken in reality
and you know
that's just something to always be
mindful of
um so yeah when you invited me to hey i
want to do a hugging face
talk i think hey i've got material we
should talk about this it's interesting
so yeah
these are all very cool findings by the
way and uh
yeah
there are a couple of questions
um which text representation was used to
psychic learn models in the waiter paper
a bag of words tf idf or word to wack um
this was before word to fact i think
it's just bag of words i could be wrong
but i think it's just bag of words
so people people have actually talked in
the chat
we should have maybe paused my bad
type model takes representation won't
matter much
but there is i feel like from what if
your findings there are subword
and gramps and stuff and maybe
they have they might have taken um
accounts you know how many words are
passing together some sort of like a
tf idea for
you know other or like a polynomial
thing
yeah so i i haven't explored vader in
full depth uh it's also like a pr it's a
it's a researchy kind of a repo so it
was mainly written to like publish the
paper i
i don't have the impression it was
actually maintained as much afterwards i
do know that um nltk actually has a
feature built on top of fader which is
pretty interesting uh there are also
other models that do similar rule-based
kind of things though so text to c has a
rule-based system called so that's on
top of spacey they have a model named
depeche mood which i just thought was a
really cool name
um
but and also like i do want to benchmark
this vader model more
because if it turns out that actually
kind of works i would love for nothing
more than to actually start writing a
package called spacey
vaders i think that would be like a
really cool name for a python package
just
yeah
yeah i like my puns i do want to
benchmark it first though because it's
ridiculous to write a package just
because of its name but
um um but but like i
i do think i will be writing a blog post
soon where i'm just going to be
comparing more of these sentiment models
just to see you know is there like a
general lesson here
i do think that sentiment is a bit of a
strange task like the more the more you
think about it qualitatively uh the more
these summary metrics just seem to
a grid search statistic really is a big
dimensionality reduction if you think
about it i think that's the
the best way to describe it i guess
we have like a couple of more questions
uh cool thoughts on extracting sentiment
using sdo zero shot models how does the
rush models work once put many optional
labels say more than 100 will it make
the process much slower
i mean
i think for sure it's going to be slower
than a rule based system just because of
the way it's you know
t5 or something like that you might know
if that's a zero shot model but like
these are typically pretty big neural
networks that we're talking so
um i also think that the tokenizer is a
subway tokenizer so that's probably
gonna bite you there uh the probability
that any one of these tokens actually
appears in the name and that's going to
influence the output
uh that's just
yeah that's just a concern i think is
also going to be in there that said i
have to admit i barely played around
with zero shot models
i've toyed around with gpd3 to do some
interesting things but
uh i don't consider myself very
knowledgeable in that field in general
so i'm also not the best person to
answer this question
and recently big science has released t0
model which is a zero shot model that
has many interesting abilities by the
way if you haven't checked it
it it
it has more it is more robust against
varying prompts and it has been trained
on various tasks and evaluated on
different tasks that it wasn't trained
on it is by the way
uh fine-tuned on t5 and they actually
checked if that
thing is
if
if the pre-trained model t5 actually
contains uh those tasks as well
so it's it's a it's a nice
generalization in my opinion let's see
uh vincent is happy
what is a vincent's
sentiment
positive okay so vincent's sentiment is
positive
now let's change this into jenny
this is negative that's weird because
i'm not asking vincent's sentiment here
so let's change that to jenny the fact
that negative came out is strange right
like that is a bit weird maybe that's
from the pretrained model or something i
don't know yeah so um i mean uh
for sure so one thing like for sure we
could uh benchmark the same thing on
this like that's actually kind of a nice
task i'll consider doing that for the
blog post i think that's fair
um
i
i do think the bigger the more neural
the model the more things could go wrong
in theory though like that is i think a
general rule to be just be kind of
mindful of i'm kind of wondering what
might be
yeah we had we saw that in the previous
example let's just try that
a sentiment positive um
what's the name of a marvel villain um
the robo
uh what was the name the villain from
the marvel movies uh thanos
thanos
okay let's see if uh
like theoretically
okay it is weird that if i put jenny in
here and then ask for vincent sentiment
that it gives negative though
this is weird uh not not necessarily
super concerning it's just weird that it
doesn't say i don't know or something
like that
anyway uh yeah there needs to be like a
fallback in uh zero shot models as well
because they usually tend to answer
regardless of their confidence but uh
i mean overall text contains the word
happy so it might be it could have just
said
positive as well
so it's weird
[Music]
i was imagining it oh okay okay yeah
well
um one thing i do want to sort of
mention it is pretty cool that you can
just go online and try out a model
before you download it that is a nice
feature here um
the fact that we i've been able to check
that live is a pretty nice one to be
honest
and there is another question
does contextual embedding help for
buys
um
so
i've not fully re i've done like basic
word embeddings in different shapes and
sizes where it's like one token one
vector eventually uh and for that i can
definitely say well no like de-biasing
doesn't work very well at all
um i would be surprised to learn that it
does work very well for
bird kind of models i mean we
we could try one
um
so
i have no idea to judge whether or not
this is the best model but it seems to
be oh but this one is spanish i think
yeah wait this is spanish so i don't
speak spanish that well
maybe we should go for a different one
nlp town multilingual okay we'll go for
that one this is a contextualized model
uh so tia
is happy today
okay so that's five
stars uh vincent is happy today
and then it will be nice if this model
if this number doesn't change right
ah okay so
on the large scale like the stars almost
like the probabilities barely shifted
but the fact that it moved even a little
bit i mean okay like i could make a
theoretical point if nothing else
yeah
but that was cool
so and this is a contextual model so
there you go
so another question is are there ways of
checking data set quality afterwards by
looking at the model predictions trained
on them
so this is going to be a bit of a plug
but you didn't know
well so that's that's typically a trick
i use but uh i also um after doing the
uh google emotions data set example i
kind of figured i need a tool for this
um this is definitely version one out
there so it's not buggy but like i
there's more to do here but i wrote this
tool called dot lab uh basically as a
tool for me and also the larger
community as well as some of my
colleagues at raza as just find bad
labels the way it kind of works like in
general the way it's designed
is you're able to say well
um there's a couple of reasons why you
might doubt a row of data it could be
that the probe of values that come out
of your model are just super low like it
doesn't have any confidence in any of
the classes if that's the case
on a train on your train set something's
up like okay check that label please but
also if you just have the wrong
prediction
if your model has the wrong prediction
on your train set also a reason to say
that's weird
now what we can do
so we can make an ensemble of all of
these different reasons
and it would be like uh this is a reason
object you just give it your psychic
learning compatible model uh you have a
dictionary of all of these and then i
will give you the order in which you
should check your
labels
i'm just going to sort the data set
where if more if more reasons agree on
something
okay that's a bigger reason to actually
go ahead and inspect
there's a couple of these reasons
implemented right now so there's an
outlier reason as well if there's an
outlier detected for sure
good to check
you can also have a model that is short
on confidence for the right label so if
the correct label is not getting enough
what is the difference between the two i
would think like if the model raises low
confidence it might be an outlier as
well
oh out of vocabulary
so an outlie well an outlier can so this
is also meant to be used outside of text
right so this all like general x goes
into models should work um but an
outlier could also be it's out of
vocabulary yeah that could be a reason
and typically i mean
some of the time the outlier reason is
going to overlap with some of the
reasons here and if that's the case that
should be seen first but if you're eight
but there's also
there's actually a counter example to
this let me just grab that
because you can also have a very high
confidence while it's an outlier
that's the one
the first blog post on grid search is
not enough suppose you have this data
set right with the red points the green
door and the blue ones right
um
what i could do is i could say let's
remove all the areas where the proba
valleys are low
and if we're going to do that we're
going to be removing the areas between
the green and the blue and like when two
areas are close to each other those are
going to be removed
but if you then zoom out then super high
confidence will still be assigned to
this region behind the red thing
i am
which is bad right yeah
and this is what all most machine
learning models do um so this is
happening with logistic regression but
um i think no this was a k-nearest
neighbor but if you do logistic
regression random forest or like
whatever neural network this is a
phenomenon that you see so you can have
a model has a super high confidence but
it's still an outlier and therefore
should still be checked
um even if you have pre-trained
embeddings or something like this can
happen yeah
um so that's why the outliers in there
basically uh i i need a system that can
prevent me from that one phenomenon and
i've seen it happen a bunch
um but anyway there's like a couple of
reasons like two models disagree there's
also a reason um you can also have like
if the top two
the suppose you have ten classes you
have the pro the confidence value for
your number one class and your number
two one
if the margin between those classes
isn't necessarily
like if that's a very small margin
a b c d and e and label a has like zero
point
i don't know uh
three and the label b has like 0.29 and
then all of these have like super small
there's a lot of confusion between two
classes
and that's also a reason to sort of
assigned out and like all these reasons
are gonna overlap a little bit but they
are like like subtly different
um there's also like the clean lab thing
where they have they have their own
heuristic it's from the label errors
project it's a sound heuristic so i
support it
in my library but the the point is that
i'm going to be adding more reasons to
this project i'm also going to be
exploring different ways of sorting
when you have your different reasons you
get a table of ones and zeros i would
like to sort that such that the most
suspicious labels end up on top
but what i don't want is that
if three reasons agree with each other
all the time and one doesn't
at some point you can ignore the one
reason because these three are always
overlapping i don't want that i would
also like to be a little bit diverse
there if possible so like sorting
algorithm is something i'm exploring i'm
interested in getting this to work for
uh spacey as well such that you can have
like entities and stuff and have some
reasons for that
um but anyway this is my little library
that i like to use for my own little
personal stuff um to find bad labels
this is what i use
so last question i guess so uh does zero
shot always have a defined fallback or
it's just the probabilistic result it it
gets post classification i never thought
about it um
i mean the word always is in there so
it's
because of that it's gonna be easy well
if i find one counter example where
there's not a defined fallback
uh then the answer is gonna be no uh but
i don't know
terribly much about these one-shot
models um
not too much
me neither i have never thought about it
but i feel like
yeah
i i'm going to investigate after the
talk but i i really i really like the
doubtlet by the way
thanks
yeah
um so we are um
like
if you if you'd like to talk about
anything else i can listen to you
forever because i i'm just as a
disclaimer
if you if you'd like to continue we can
continue as i'll just say well so one
thing i'm kind of curious about like so
interesting you know like whatever
like your findings are incredibly
interesting and it blows my mind and you
know it gives me a different perspective
well so one thing i'm curious about from
your end
i've been talking about some like some
some things that i might want to change
about the way hugging face currently
kind of works right now and that has to
do with the model cards but then again i
have no idea how complex it is to force
users to use these model cards
uh i was i'm actually quite pleased the
fact that there is even is a feature for
these model cards and that someone else
can also make an edit uh so those things
seems kind of sensible but like after
hearing what i've said
like are you are you thinking about
other ways now that you might be able to
use these model cards as well like i'm
kind of curious about that too
because you have the hugging face
perspective right like i don't
in that sense
i mean
uh
maybe like
for the post prediction your
findings are
something close to your findings is that
maybe people could actually
um leverage something like adult lab and
instead of putting
those metrics like that because they
usually resp they are usually good
because it's a state of art you know
birth and you know you do
some
optimization on birth when you are
training we also have this tensorboard
in the model cards
we could maybe put something like that
uh the the predictions and you know like
the the doubts the reasons
uh i feel like that would be cool uh
now that i think about it but it's just
uh it's just my opinion one thing i
guess that is good to mention because
it's uh i
i think there's also so there was a
paper a couple of i saw uh i saw a
couple days ago where they said hey
there's this entity data set is quite
well known has has label hours too like
that's the conclusion of the data set so
what they went ahead and did
is they made a corrected version of that
data set and when i was googling it i
did find it unhugging face so the the
paper the authors of the paper yeah so
identifying incorrect labels in the
colonel
corpus
i don't know the name of the correct
data set but i did find that the authors
also added a data set on hugging face
where they were linking to the old one
and said ours actually has like a
thousand label corrections or something
like that
um so that is something i think is
pretty interesting too about hugging
phase at some point you could have
multiple versions of the data set where
uh the community at some point just kind
of goes well we've done our best and we
are pretty sure these labels are
due for a fix that is something that you
could at some point maybe you have on
top of hugging phase
until then though um to anyone listening
if you have a model um here um
take model card serious and consider
adding what the intended use case for a
model is
but i would love to see more of that if
i'm honest will also make my life at
rasa easier
because i don't have to benchmark
everything
that would be nice if people could
actually
we have released this dataset
measurements tool and it also has some
good um it's in the spaces it's
currently trending if you'd like to take
a look at it
uh
uh there is a lot of nice uh exploration
uh in there like
if if people would actually use this
before training a model
and add a couple of disclaimers based on
the data set on the model cards that the
data set
was used to train
the model
one thing one thing i saw this morning
one thing that i thought was a really
nice touch is the zipslop fit to anyone
doing nlp if you don't know what zip's
law is just look it up it's it's kind of
just one of these
linguistic features that is kind of nice
to keep in the back of your mind because
it kind of explains how language works
as well and the fact that you might have
a data set that doesn't follow that i
think is also pretty interesting
anyway uh there's also some cool stuff
you could do here i do agree
um
there should be
someone said there should be a model
card guide but there is one as far as i
know
oh i i just have to check it that there
should be one in the documentation
i remember one for data sets definitely
remember there should be one form
one and we have also renewed our
documentation
okay well it might be around here and
there's also a paper based on it by uh
by margaret mitchell
uh and to end timothy gerbi if i recall
correctly no no it's it's not the
stochastic pills it's the model card
there's there's a paper based on model
card and it's uh benefits and
everything
um yeah this is what didn't it but tim
and gabriel
i didn't know that's that's cool i mean
it's a long list of people uh but
definitely it's a good paper uh
definitely good paper that that's
definitely true uh i remember i think i
did a paper reading session with rachel
you can find it on youtube as well uh
but this was a good paper
definitely
anyway thank you so much we should do
this more often uh like whenever you
find something interesting about liking
facebook maybe next time for an identity
recognition biases
uh yeah well um i am gonna be uh doing
some stuff with bad labels in the next
quarter somewhere on youtube maybe uh so
when i have some cool results there i'll
definitely let you know and we can use
more often it'll be fun
i agree it's nice nice to see you again
yeah
very nice to see you thank you so much
for coming
and thanks everyone for listening uh see
ya
thanks for listening